we're on problem 36 and it says what is
the area in square units of the
trapezoid shown below
so when you just look at this you're
like okay trapezoid do i know the the
formula for the area of a trapezoid and
you might get confused and all of that
you say well trapezoid i can break it up
into a rectangle and a triangle if i
were to draw a line right here
if i draw a line right there then i've
broken up the trapezoid into a rectangle
in a triangle and then if i know the
dimensions of each of those i know the
dimensions i know the area of each of
them and then i know the area of the
entire thing
so let's see what's this height right
here
or this width i should say
well we're going from zero to what x is
equal to x is equal to eight here right
i just went straight down from x is
equal to eight y is equal to five so
this dimension is eight and then when we
go from x is equal to eight x is equal
to twelve how far is that well that's
going to be 4
right so this is 4 and this is 8.
fair enough
and then how high is this rectangle
we're going from y is equal to 0 to y is
equal to 5 so that's 5. and of course
this is 5 as well so we're done we're
ready to figure out the area the area of
the rectangle part is 8 times 5 that's
40.
the area of this triangle is 5 times 4
times 1 half right if we didn't put that
one half we'd be figuring out the area
of this rectangle right there so it's
five times four is twenty times one half
is ten
so the area of both of these combined is
ten plus forty
fifty
thirty seven
the figure below is a square with four
congruent parallelograms inside this
looks interesting what is the area in
square units of the shaded portion so
the shaded portion is the whole square
minus the area of the parallelogram so
the whole square that's easy it's 12 and
the height is 12 but since we know it's
a square we know the width also has to
be 12
right
so the area of the whole square is 144
and now we have to figure out the area
if we know the area of one of the
parallelograms we know the area of all
of the parallelograms because they are
congruent
so let's see if we can figure out the
area of one of the parallelograms
so i'll
there is actually a formula for the area
of a parallelogram it's actually just
the base times the height
and they actually give us that but let
me show you that they give us that
because it might not be obvious to you
so if i let me try to draw it so
i want to use my line tool
nope that's not the line tool
so one side
and go straight like that
and come down like that
good enough
okay now if i look at just this
parallelogram
they tell us that the height here is
three right this height is three
and i know it's the height because they
told me this is a 90 degree angle and
they tell us that the base is five
and i'm telling you that the area of a
parallelogram is just the base times the
height is equal to 15.
but you shouldn't just take my word for
you that should make intuitive sense to
you and the way to think about it
intuitively is imagine if we were to
take
if we were to take this part of the
parallelogram if we just cut it right
here
and if we were to move it over here
if we were to cut that off and move it
over here
then the parallelogram would look
something like this
you'd have the part that we didn't cut
off
right and then you move the cutoff part
over here
and now the dimensions this base would
be five and then this height would be
three and the area of this rectangle is
fifteen and there's no reason why the
area of this should be any different
than that we just rearranged its parts
so that's why the area of a
parallelogram is just the base times the
height so the area of each of these
parallelograms are 15
so the area of all of them combined is
15 times 4 which is 60 so 144
minus 60 is what ad4
84 and that's choice
b
problem 38 what is the area in square
meters of the trapezoid shown below so
to figure out the area we could break it
up into these rectangles and triangles
to figure out the area of this rectangle
we need to know
we need to know its height we know this
height actually we need that we'll need
that to figure out the area of the
triangles as well
so what's this height right there
so let's see we know that this
this distance is going to be six it's a
rectangle
that distance is going to be six if that
distance is six and both of these are
five both of these triangles here are
going to be congruent
right
because this length is equal to this
length
this length is equal to this length
and we also well we could also make you
know this angle is equal to that angle
but anyway so what is are these is let
me do another color
what's the length of these two green
sides
let's call it x
right well we know that when you add x
plus 6 plus x it has to equal 12 that
whole top part
so you get x plus x is 2x
plus 6 is equal to 12. 2x is equal to 6
x is equal to 3 and you might have been
able to solve that in your head that if
that's 6 and these are the same that
both of these are going to be three
and now we can use that information to
figure out this height right there right
because if we just draw this triangle
right there
that's three that's
this is some unknown side a
and you might already recognize we're
going to use a pythagorean theorem and
this is a very typical type of right
triangle so you might already be able to
guess what a is but we'll solve for it
so we can know that a squared
plus 3 squared
is equal to the hypotenuse squared the
side opposite the 90 degree angle
squared so that is equal to 25
5 squared is 25 a squared
plus 9 is equal to 25 a squared is equal
to 16 a is equal to 4.
a is equal to 4 and now we're ready to
figure out the area
what's the area of the rectangle 6 times
4 it's 24
what's the area of each of these
triangles three times four times one
half
three times four is twelve times
one-half is six
so the area of that triangle is six the
air of this triangle is six so six plus
24 plus six is 36.
b
problem 39
what is the area in square inches of the
triangle below
interesting okay so this is a
equilateral triangle all the sides are
equal and so we could actually say that
this since these two triangles are
symmetric we can say that's equal to
that and you know this comes to a
general formula for the area of an
equilateral triangle but let's just
figure it all out so this is so this
side is going to be 5
and this side is going to be 5.
if this is 5 and that's 10 what is this
side right here let's call it x
pythagorean theorem
this is the hypotenuse so x squared plus
5 squared plus 25
is going to be equal to the hypotenuse
squared which is equal to 100
x squared is equal to 100 minus 25 75
x is equal to the square root of 75
75 is 25 times 3 right so that's equal
to the square root of 25
times 3 which is equal to the square
root of 25 times the square root of 3
which is equal to 5
roots of three so x is equal to five
roots of three
and now what's the area of just this
right triangle right here this one on
the right side
well it's base is five its height is
five roots of three so it's going to be
one half
times the base five
times its height five roots of three
and that's what one half times five
times five so it's 25
root three over two and that's just this
triangle right there well this triangle
is going to have the same is going to
have the exact same area right they're
congruent triangles
so the area of the figure is this times
two
so two times that is equal to just the
25 root three and that's choice
b
next problem problem forty
the perimeter of two squares are in a
ratio of four to nine what is the ratio
between the areas of the two squares let
me draw
let me draw straw let's draw two squares
so that's one square
unless we draw another square
that's another square
and let's say that
this the sides of this are x
right
and the sides of this one are y
so they're saying the perimeters of the
two squares are a ratio of four to nine
so the perimeter of the first square is
4x right x plus x plus x plus x
4x the perimeter of the second square is
4y
so that's the ratio of the perimeter of
the first square to the perimeter of the
second square
and then that is equal to four to nine
that is equal to
four
to nine
and they say what is the ratio between
the areas of the two squares so they
want us to figure out the area of the
first square is x squared and the ratio
right x base times height x times x and
the area of the second square is y times
y
so they want us to figure out
what that is equal to
right
well this is
x squared over y squared this is the
same thing as
x over y
squared so if we can figure out what x
over y is equal to we can just square it
and we'll get x squared over y squared
so let's try to do that
so they give us this let's see
if we divide well this just simplifies
right four over four no reason x over y
is equal to four over nine
right
x over nine is equal to four over nine
so let's substitute that here so x
squared over y squared is equal to x
over y squared which is equal to
4 9
squared which is equal to
over 81. or the ratio of the areas of
the two squares is 16 to 81
choice d
maybe we could fit one more
problem in there actually no i'm over 10
minutes i'll stop right there see you in
the next video